[Music]
okay I'd like to welcome everybody to
tonight's opening class we're going over
the rui lopez or the spanish chess
opening spanish game they caught rui
Lopez was a Spanish bishop who invented
this particular opening way back I think
in the 1700s not sure about that but he
was the Catholic bishop he liked to play
chess and they named this after him this
is considered the strongest opening for
white
if black you play pawn to King four to
square so strikes out with this move
this is Bobby Fischer you know who he is
right
America's greatest player ever
world champion this was his favorite
opening his white yes double King pawn
both sides and then you bring out the
night it attacks the pawn the pawns not
defended right so black has to defend
the pawn so he brings his Knight out
now if the bishop goes to c4 what
opening what's the name of that open
Italian game this is considered a more
complicated aggressive opening in the
Italian game the Italian game is
perfectly fine and a lot of people like
to play it including grandmasters
they've been playing it a lot too last
few years but Bobby Fischer like this
way say the knight protects the pawn on
e5 that pawn black is defending by
definition when you start a game white
moves first White has the first move
advantage he gets to move a piece and
well first he starts out with a pawn he
puts it in the middle of the board the
center squares are the four squares
right in the middle so you always move
the pawn two squares not one when you're
white you grab as much
as you can when you start out white has
the first four rows that's White's
territory Black's territory or the next
four rows up the board but if you're
looking at it from black side you have
one two three four that's your territory
now the opening phase of a game is you
they call it development what but what
all that means is you bring your pieces
from their starting positions at the
back row and the pawns and you put them
on the best squares the best squares
they can go to toward the middle of the
board so that you control squares chess
is a game of controlling the squares the
person who controls more squares can
push the other guy backwards and then
once you pushing backwards and you make
them defend his position you find
attacking moves and you find ways you
might want to pawn or a piece so the
opening face is it's like in a war the
generals don't start any action until
they mobilize the army right you take
them from the civilians you draft them
you train them you bring them to the
front line then you start so just as a
war game
you bring your forces the pieces and
pawns from their starting positions try
to control the oh it's many squares as
you can and every move you move a
different pawn and piece so you get all
your pieces developed you don't move one
piece twice in the opening because if
you move this Knight here and here in a
way
you wasted a move because you could have
moved this Knight here and you'd have
two knights out so your forces would be
two knights whereas if you move this guy
twice this guy's stuck back
here at home you see that's called rapid
development so if you notice every move
is with a keep on move
grabbing space and then the pieces come
up and grab and grab space now
the night moves here attacking the pawn
this Knight moves here
now the bishop comes here and it's
attacking the knight that defends to the
pawn eventually white is going to
threaten Bishop takes Knight and then
the pawns not protected and then Knight
takes pawn wins a pawn but it doesn't
threaten it right now let's say white
could make another move right this very
minute and tried to win this pawn here I
this blacks move but I'm gonna give
white as a teacher an extra move just to
show you what the threat is
that it's not a threat so imagine Bishop
takes Knight black takes with this pod
why would black take with this pawn and
not this pawn what do you think
what do you think it does it opens up
this file for the Queen what else does
it open up what else can get out after
that pawn moves this pawn moves here
the bishop it can come out this way now
if he did this pawn the Queen's still
stuck behind this pawn right and the
bishop can't come to the middle we only
can come to the side and the only
squares here and he'd be behind the pawn
here that would be terrible
so the only correct move is this pawn
takes now if this Knight takes the pawn
it looks like white wins the pawn right
but look the Queen can move from here to
here attack the knight that's here and
the pawn that's here this pawn is
undefended the knight is undefended the
knight has to retreat here and black can
take the pawn with check getting the
pawn back so the point is this looks
like it threatens to win a pawn but it
doesn't not yet nevertheless it's still
a good move as soon as white protects
this pawn then Bishop takes Knight
Knight takes pawn becomes a real threat
and black will have to defend against it
so we're gonna look at how black does
that now this particular there are
different ways black can play the really
Lopez here but we're looking at the
chigorin defense and the key move at
this point is a thick and what this does
it drives the bishop back here we're
bishops and Knights how many points are
they worth in the point system three
each three each a rook is five the Queen
is how much right and upon right
and I would point out that when you say
a knight or Bishop is worth three points
what's worth five OH three point three
people try to some players over refine
the point system its needlessly
complicated just stick with this simple
three points for Bishop at night five
for work King there's no value because
if you lose the key they don't bet it
has value but they don't give it a point
value because if you lose your King the
game's over through checkmate so there's
no point the point value helps you
decide whether to make a trade or not if
you can give up a bishop and win a rook
that's three points and you get five so
you do it
the other thing about the point system
is what you're really saying is the
bishop is worth three pawns it's based
on a pond with a point value of one and
a work is worth five pawns the other
thing is even though bishops and Knights
are given three points grandmasters
generally consider the bishop to be a
little stronger than a knight so if
white takes the knight that's considered
a concession to black and black can get
an even game easier than if white
retains the bishop and retreats here
retreating here he saves the future
threat of Bishop takes Knight if he does
Bishop takes Knight he's given up a
piece that's a little better for a
knight and it lets black have an easy
equality white loses the first move
advantage so the next move is Bishop to
a four okay so black needs to move now
you typically move your minor pieces the
bishops the Knights up before you can
move the rooks because you can't get the
roots up to your castle one side or the
other and you have to clean
out the back road open up lines for the
rook now you can't move this bishop not
yet blocked by the pawns
so it's choices he can move that bishop
for that night now in this defense you
develop the knight to f6 so notice that
the knight
you always bring the Knights to the
center you wouldn't go here to the side
a knight on the side of the board can
only go to four squares a knight in the
middle can go to eight so if you put the
knight on the edge of the board you're
controlling for less squares than you
would if you put him in the middle so
the chest opening principle is to always
put your Knights I'm almost always f6
and c6 okay now the other thing to keep
in mind is White had a pawn and two
pieces developed black had a pawn and a
knight he also moved this pawn but this
pawn only moved up one square doesn't do
much so black was a piece and
development behind he has to keep pace
with white he has to develop a knight or
Bishop he did the night because the
knight attacks the pawn the pawns not
defended whenever you can move a piece
into the game and make a threat that's
the move you want to make because the
threat forces white to at least think
about defend how he's going to defend
this pawn it limits White's choices okay
now white is playing very aggressively
he decides not to defend the pawn
directly and he castles
the other thing about openings that you
need to keep in mind is every move in
the opening has a specific purpose every
square the pawns and pieces on
grandmasters have determined that
they're the best places for those pieces
and pawns if you want to learn the
opening some beginners memorize the
first 10 moves
some might memorize the first 15 moves
it does you very little good it's more
important to know where the pieces go
and even more important to know why they
go there so once you know why the pieces
go there then memorizing the specific
move order is much easier because it
makes sense if you just memorize an open
e by repetition and you don't know why
the moves were made when you're done
with your 10 moves you don't know what
to do so that's how you should study
opening so anyway White Castle but he
indirectly defends to this pod if Knight
takes the pawn see the rook can move
here attack the knight and if the knight
moves back this Knight can take the pawn
Knight takes rook takes knight check so
white really did defend the pawn and
Knight takes pawn would be a bad move
for black castling is considered a
development move just like bringing a
knight Bishop and Knight up so now
White's the head and development by one
move black now needs to get he wants to
castle to see how you get the King
behind these three pawns in the side of
the board it's safe this is a wall of
pawns and they protect the King the
pawns and and they're protected by the
knight this one is protected by the rook
this is very safe the other thing about
castling the work comes from the corner
he
and can move to the middle of the board
and support the pawn and make attacks
toward the king okay now black needs to
catch up so he develops this bishop here
then he can castle the next move so the
next move is Bishop here now white moves
his rook from next to the king to the
e-file the e1 square it protects the
pawn and there's no longer a possible
Knight takes pawn it would lose a piece
okay
now black needs to make a development
move he wouldn't move the Knights he
could move up he could move this pawn
here that's a different opening called
the Steinitz defense deferred it's
perfectly playable he can move the pawn
here it would protect this pawn and let
the bishop out but the opening we're
going through tonight is better than the
steinitz defense and also when see how
the rook protects this pawn now white is
threatening Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes Knight takes pawn and he would win
this black pawn the Queen here no longer
works because this pawns protected the
knight retreats attacking the Queen and
the Queen has to move and can't take the
pawn back so black
remember he moved this pawn here to push
the rook the bishop from here to here
but it also gave black the option of
following up with this pawn here here
driving the bishop away from the knight
leaving the knight
protecting the pawn so white can't win
so that's the move b5 the bishop
retreats and now black moves the pawn
here to let the bishop out this way but
more importantly this pawn is the key
defensive point in black hold position
black reinforces this pawn by putting
the pawn here he has a pawn chain that's
very strong defensive setup
so he plays d6 now white is the
aggressor there are a number of good
moves white could play he could develop
the knight here then the bishop Knight
and pawn would control this square this
square is only defended by the knight so
he would have two pieces and a pawn
against one he could plant the knight in
here he could also move the pawn here
like black have the nice pawn chain let
his Bishop out but white because he has
the first move advantage he's going to
adopt a more aggressive position his
plan is to get two pawns side-by-side in
the center he's going to move this pawn
here where to text the key black
defensely pawn here
but white can't do it right now because
black would just do pawn takes pawn and
white would never get his two pawns here
so as a preliminary move white roots
this pawn here which protects this pawn
move and if Quan takes pawn the pawn
from here takes back and white gets his
two pawns in the center that's a very
aggressive attacking setup only possible
for white because white has the first
new advantage so the right move for
white is c3 and now white is going to
play here that will let the bishop out
and these two pawns fight for all these
squares it's the most aggressive setup
white can do in this position now black
needs to get his King out of the middle
of the board and he needs to develop
this bishop well where should he put the
bishop if he goes here white can drive
it away with pawn here he can't go in
here is not good y can just take it and
double the pawns and black would have a
pawn weakness actually black needs to
defer making a decision about this
bishop till later so black is best move
is to castle to get this King out of the
middle of the board
yeah that's possible
and it happens sometimes but we'll get
to that later in the game okay right now
the most urgent thing this pawn is
coming here and then white can open up
the middle of the board with pawn takes
pawn the king doesn't want to be in the
middle of the board with a rook headed
toward it King needs to castle and
that's the key move okay so now I told
you that pawn to Queen 4 is White's idea
with this move right it turns out that
it's not good for white to play it yet
if the pawn comes here black has an
equalizing move it leads to complete
equality he moves the bishop here and
pins the knight which defends the pawn
so imagine in your mind that this pawn
is here and the bishop is here well I'll
show it to you on the screen so if white
plays pawn to Queen for the right move
for black is to pin the knight now the
threat in this position is pawn takes
pawn pawn takes pawn this knight is
pinned to the Queen
then it's Bishop takes Knight if Queen
takes bishop the Queen's protecting this
pawn so if the Queen takes the bishop
the knight takes the pawn attacking the
Queen and Bishop the Queen moves he
takes the bishop and black wins upon
that's why this pin is so strong now the
alternative is White doesn't have to
lose the pawn if it was blacks move he
would do Bishop takes Knight he doesn't
have to do Queen he can do Quan takes
well look he needs the three pawns in
front of the King to protect his King if
the pawn goes here
there's
file is open toward the king he has the
weak King position he doesn't lose the
pawn but and the double pawns are weak
black wood almost white would almost be
lost if that happened therefore before
he plays pawn to Queen four he has to
prevent the bishop move what's the best
move for white to prevent Bishop to g4
who would like to hazard a guess about
that go ahead h3 that's that's the key
move that's the main move for white in
the Rory Lopez and more than one
variation but this is the chi goring now
we're at the point where the Chi Gorn
defense actually starts this is the
major there's two major ways to play the
chicoy defense starts with Knight to a4
it drives the bishop the bishops in the
strong attacking position here and
affecting the center square here and
this square a great diagonal for the
bishop the knight drives it back here
remember a bishop is worth more than a
knight White's not going to what black
take the bishop that would he would lose
his best attacking piece so he moves to
the bishop here now the bishop here is
blocked by his pawn you see that so the
bishop is it will take a while for the
bishop to get to a good post after
retreating here that's why this is a
good move the other reason
when the knight is back here I'll put it
back
notice that the knight blocked this pawn
so the pawn can't move here or here if
the pawn was here or here it would fight
for this square or this square key
Center squares
so not only does the night move drive
the bishop back it frees this pawn to
move in the future that's the major idea
white retreats the bishop now black
immediately plays this pawn up two
squares
notice that now he's fighting for this
score he knows that this pawn is going
to move here and white and black are
fighting for this square he has two
pawns but he's not going to trade so
much not he's gonna keep this pawn here
no matter what there's an option to
trade this pawn and open up this file
you're gonna see that in the game the
other thing is by moving the pawns up
look the Queen protects the knight
remember the pardon was here now the
Queen can move from here to here and
defend the pawns and the once the Queen
goes here the bishop moves out then the
rooks can move so you'll see all that
white carries out his pawn advance which
I told you about now he has his two
pawns in the center that was his most
aggressive setup now he white is now
threatening to win this pawn pawn takes
pawn pawn takes pawn Knight takes pawn
so black defends the pawns by moving the
Queen up one square and if pawn takes
pawn pawn takes pawn the Queen protects
the pawn that's here in this opening
black maintains this pawn the whole game
this is the key it blocks this pawn this
white pawn if this quad could move up
here it would open up this line to
Black's King side and the knight and the
Queen could come up here and attack
blacks King so by keeping the pawn here
it blocks this pawn which blocks to the
bishop and Pete white on white side of
the board now he's got his wife Scout
his pawns for the way he wants he needs
to develop this night and this bishop
which haven't moved yet
so you say well should I blew the bishop
for the night what does the audience
think he should move and where well if
you go to e3 that's okay
it protects this pawn we're d5o g5 well
that's okay but black hits you with h6
then where do you move the bishop here
or here if you go here it blocks the
Queen protecting the pawn well you could
go here but that can be bad sometimes
black can play here and the bishop comes
here and is blocked by the pawns the
answer is the correct move is to move
the knight first leaving the bishop
decision for later on until the position
becomes more clear where the bishop
should go that's the same reason black
didn't move that bishop it wasn't clear
where the bishop goes yet so the knight
has a clear plan the knight is going to
go here and in the Rui Lopez or Spanish
game the night goes here when the
Knights here it's only partly developed
it blocks the bishop can't get out it
has to move they move it down here and
it's got one more move so it's a three
movement over they bring it either here
or here they usually bring it here it
frees the bishop and the night here
protects the key Center pawn and
prepares to hop up here and when it gets
up here it attacks this bishop in this
pawn and this square so it's an
attacking maneuver but it takes three
moves to get where white wants it to go
so the right move is Knight Bishop to d2
okay now black knows that the knight is
going to go here and here and White's
going to start the King side attack
black wants to open up some lines on the
Queen side and see how the Queen is on
this file and the Queen's going to
attack this bishop he's going to open up
this file by pawn takes pawn that gives
black what they call a counter-attack
white is going to attack this way black
is going to open up the file move this
bishop somewhere and move a rook here
working Queen are going to threaten
Queen takes bishop so when your opponent
tries to attack you you have to defend
threats but you also need to find a way
to counter attack your opponent so the
right move is pawn takes pawn white
takes back remember I told you move the
pawn here so he could move here and keep
the two pawns
yes stick back with the pawn now
remember I told you this Knight here
only has four squares and he has eight
black moves the knight back here so he
gets the eight squares and the knight
here protects this pawn and also attacks
this pawn and can move here sometimes
so black retreats the knight that's a
good move in this case I did say don't
move it more than once in the opening
generally this is an exception when the
knight moved here that was moved to it
drove the bishop back so that was a good
defensive move to drive the bishop back
now that the knight accomplished the
purpose with the bishop he retreats here
and that's acceptable because he helps
protect this pawn and threatens this
pawn and he goes back to affecting eight
squares instead just four so it's just
as rules and there are exceptions to
them this is an exception to the rule
that you shouldn't move the piece more
than once in the opening ok now white
needs to move the knight if he goes with
his intended move down here notice that
black can take the pawn Knight takes
Knight pawn takes Knight and he can't
play Queen takes pawn this Bishop would
not be protected and the Queen could
take the bishop so Knight here
worked for white anymore he has to
change his plan he moves the night here
where it helps protect this pod and then
if black trades this pawn the knight
takes and the Queen continues to protect
the bishop so this is a forced move by
White Knight to b3 now black has tried
different moves here but the modern move
is to this Knight defend this pawn and
black can get equality by driving the
night away from this good square how can
black try to drive the night away from
b3 any ideas
where well that has a flaw that this
pawn could move here attacking the
knight and Bishop and black would lose a
piece
any other ideas yeah comes up here
that's exactly what he does so this is
an aggressive move by black but it has a
good purpose of driving the night away
from a good square and that's a
principle in the opening you not only
want to put your pawns and pieces on the
best squares you want to drive your
opponent's pieces away from their best
squares so that's what blacks do it okay
now he knows he's going to have to move
the knight the pawn is going to come
here he's going to hurry up and move
this bishop here to protect the pawn
then he can move the knight here and not
block the bishop in the bishop will be
here not here so the Knights behind the
bishop so the right move is to move the
bishop out right now and protect that
Center pawn on d4 black carries out his
threat now white can retreat this is
still a balanced even position you see
both sides they're jockeying for squares
and control white is better in the
center with these two pawns and see how
Saul's pieces
or in the center black holds the center
he's holy in the center he's not
attacking the center he's trying to
develop his pieces to keep up with white
and he wants to move the bishop once he
moves to the bishop here or here he can
move one of the rooks here and then he
threatens Knight takes pawn Knight takes
pawn takes Bishop takes and Queen takes
Bishop that's how black gets threats in
this position okay now but so black
needs to move that Bishop on c8 it's
finally time to move the bishop where
should black put that bishop any guesses
where you were talking about Bishop to
b7 you could you can't go here we talked
about the pawn fork you can't go here
the question now is which squares better
this square or this square anybody care
to guess how about you this pawn right
it looks good but it doesn't work the
reason it doesn't work is white roots
the pawn here driving the night away and
then the bishop is pointing at two pawns
and has no future moves the right move
is Bishop here and if the pawn comes
here see how the bishop here guards this
square remember this nights gonna go
here here and here
the bishop guards that square can take
the knight and if the pawns here the
bishop can defend this way and move this
way and it's not blocked by the pond
whereas if the bishop here has no moves
at all he's blocked by these pawns and
he's blocked by these pawns on the Queen
side so the right vote was Bishop to
Queen 2 or Bishop to d7 ok now White has
developed all his minor pieces right
he's Castle he moved his rook to the
middle so he developed this rook what
piece hasn't white developed yet
what do you think which piece hasn't
moved for white okay
doesn't it make sense to move this where
it can do something to active where
should the rook go it's on a file
pointing at the Queen right and the
Queen wants to take the bishop it
defends the bishop the bishop can move
in the future and threaten pawn here the
Knights pin to the Queen white you
threaten to win a piece so that is the
right move remember you bring in all
your forces into the game the one force
white has that hasn't come into the game
is this this is clearly the piece to
move and as he said he can go here here
this would not do anything it's behind a
pawn and it blocks the bishop retreating
so this is the only move and that's
what's plate all right now black if you
see that there's a rook aim toward your
queen even if there's a few pieces in
between should you feel good about that
or should be a little uneasy about that
if you were black I would be a little
uneasy about it it might be prudent to
move your queen out of the way of the
rook that's call a preventing move so
we're gonna do a preventing move with
the Queen now the question is where
should the Queen move any ideas where
the Queen should move yeah what are your
choices the black Queen it's lined up on
the rook we don't like that we need to
move the Queen somewhere it can go here
here here here here or here or here what
you're those squares will you pick here
what's it doing up here well it does
come down this way but this night
defended by the Bishop Knight and Queen
so there's not much future here the
right move is to go here out of the way
but you're pointing on this diagonal
remember you said it would be good to
put the bishop here aiming toward the
pawn
well black kind of goes by that button
so the bishop he puts the Queen there
and the Queen notice protects this pawn
this pawn can't be protected by another
black pawn because we move this pawn way
up here to drive the night away right
now if the pawn was back here it could
move here and protect the pawn so it's
important for the Queen or some other
piece to protect this pawn so the Queen
can do two things by moving it gets out
of the way of the rook and protects the
pawn so that's why that's this move is
made okay now there are no real threats
to be made remember I told you white
wants to move the knight here and here
he couldn't move the knight here earlier
because the Queen was attacking this
bishop the Queen's no longer attacking
the bishop so white can do is maneuver
now that's what he does he moves his
knight over now black has all his minor
pieces that Queen he's canceled what
pieces does black need to activate what
do you think yeah so the question is
where should which work should move and
where should it move any ideas
yeah the center which rook should go to
the center
so job you're gonna move both rooks
eventually but you work to the Senators
the right idea king work first the most
the best place to put the King work is
right behind this bishop it helps
protect this pawn remember this pawn has
to stay here the whole game though the
rook protects the bishop the bishop can
move out of the way and then the if the
rook behind the bishop would maybe
threaten pawn takes pawn in the future
opening the work at night on this pawn
black would counter-attack on this pond
indirectly yes to move the bishop out of
the way to do it but so that worked at
EA tis the right move F to e 8 now later
he's going to move this rook here to
contest this open file you know what an
open file is right everybody it's a file
without either white or black pawns on
it a half-open file there's one pawn of
white or black so it's half open to the
other side anyway this is completely
open this Rick's going to come here and
try to trade off rooks and simplify the
game you don't want to let your opponent
have an open file with a rook on it
without opposing it at some point okay
now I told you the night maneuver so the
knight comes up here alright so now the
knight all the minor pieces are pretty
much where they're gonna be
and this Knight is aiming here but
notice we were smart black left the
bishop here and it guards this square if
the knight comes here the bishop just
takes it and there's no he wipes out
White's piece that's finally enters into
black territory remember I said this is
white and these are black so White's
finally getting ready to maybe move a
piece in the blacks territory but blacks
already defending it okay now
black okay remember this bishop is
blocking the rook behind this pawn if
the bishop moves out of the way then
black can open up an attack on this pond
by pawn takes pawn and the rook night
and if this Knight moves out of the way
by Knight takes pawn then the Queen
Knight and Rick attack this pawn and
it's possible that white black threatens
to win the pawn so black is going to
move that bishop out of the way in
prayer this is the case of preference
but I could also move the rook here
they're both good moves in this
particular game black chose to rule his
Bishop back and he plays this Mook so
see how it opens up the rook to this
pawn and after Knight takes Knight takes
Bishop takes the three pieces attack
that pawn he can't win it though but it
builds up a potential threat for the
future anyway White is he wants to this
pawn and he's going to load up pieces on
this pawn which has to be protected by
pieces we're at move 19 in the opening a
lot of opening books stop right here the
evaluation of the game between two
grandmasters it was only a year or two
ago is that the position is even its
balance that doesn't mean it's a draw it
means both sides have chances white can
attack someplace and black can
counter-attack and if both sides play
correctly it should end in a draw but
chess it's very easy to make mistakes oh
not that many games ending draw so
anyway white Moose is Queen to King two
or to e2 he's pointing toward this pawn
he's going to move the bishop here
opening up the rook and the bishop and
queen are gonna threaten Bishop takes
pawn that's the one target in blacks
position white can aim at so he starts
staying there blacks going to make a
defensive move now with the squad move
he takes this square away from this
knight in Bishop so they can't move into
blacks territory purely defensive move
it also gives the king and xscape square
in the future it if he should meet it
you doesn't need it now but he might in
the future so white moves his Bishop up
and he threatens to win the pawn black
uses their different lines but the black
chooses to defend it with rook here
working queen defend the pawn adequately
it's still an even game they computer I
put this in my computer system you know
the chess computer they call them
engines that analyze and tell you what
move should be played the chess computer
engines now are better than the world
champion so they're very reliable the
comedian said that the Grandmaster
played black had a better way to get a
completely even game instead of rook to
Bishop 8 the computer says he should
move his Bishop from here see when the
bishop was here the two rooks weren't
protecting each other right and the
bishop kind of blocked the rooks
interacting now black is defending he
would like to trade off some pawns and
pieces if he plays here he's got the
knight the bishop and the knight and the
pawn all attacking this pawn and he can
trade pieces by Knight takes pawn Knight
takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop takes
pawn takes he's actually threatening
temporarily to win the pawn so he puts
pressure here and he forces white either
removed
on here or to take the pawn here white
can move here and drive the knight back
but the knight could go back here and
come back by going here and come up here
so blacks not worried about pawn here if
white moves here white gives up forever
the ability to take this pawn remember I
told you this is the key to Black's
position so this does gain space because
the pawn moves up to the fifth row and
is in blacks territory and it opens up
space behind the pawns for white it's
not a bad move but he doesn't want to
give up taking this key pawn of blacks
so in this line the computer recommends
taking the pawn see the threat was black
was gonna win the pawn so he either had
to move it or take it computer says he
should take it now black can trade off a
few pieces to get an even position not
with the pawn see if he takes with the
pawn he can't trade any pieces he takes
with the night the night here attacks
this night and this Bishop if he gets
the opportunity he'd take the bishop I
told you it's more than the night and he
can take this bishop now and trade that
bishop and get a completely even game
any simplified things so the right move
his knight takes white takes with the
knight his white doesn't want to let him
take the bishop now he takes with the
pawn see he maintained the pawn here
this pawn came up here he kept the key
pawn that blocks this pawn so black
successfully defended the position now
they say it's even they'll show you a
few moves white can do rook rook up then
he can bring this work here and try to
control the file but it doesn't work
because black
we can move his Rick over see how they
threatened to trade each other off-white
to move this Rick over black takes rook
takes and now rook here would be a
mistake because the Queen has to
preclude has to protect this pawn and
the bishop has to protect this pawn
because there are two pieces on it
rook here would let rook takes rook and
either the Queen or Bishop would have to
take it and this pawn would be lost
rook yours would be a bad move a lot of
times it's good to trade off all the
rooks but not in this case the best move
for black is to move his King up I told
you it was that annex Capel he moves
there the other thing about that is if
he goes here
rook takes rook it's not Czech so it
gives black more options that's a purely
defensive move and it's even but going
back to this position in the game black
chose rook to b8 which is also leads to
an equal game not quite as equal as the
computer responds okay so here white
those pot pawn takes again Knight takes
to trade off some pieces Knight takes
pawn takes again see how black is
maintained as pawn here at all costs
and it blocks White's pieces from
invading Black's territory and these
pawns keep white from doing anything on
the Queen side black actually threatens
at some point to move this pawn here and
then these two pawns can advance block
white wants to block these pawns from
advancing so he plays this move
now he moved it to squares and see how
it blocks these two pawns so these pawns
can't move anymore
this one could move here but it would be
unprotected here and white could attack
it and win it at some point
so this pawn really can't move here
though legally he could move here it
would be a bad move he needs to stay
here where he's protected by this pot so
that if the pawn stays here this pawn is
blocked forever it's advantageous to
black to maintain equality remember when
the pawn moves up twice black has the
option of taking it pawn takes pawn and
piss off that's the right move okay
white takes back and black moves up here
attacking the rook rook moves over here
black moves his Bishop to e6 attacking
this pawn he leaves this pawn under
defended it's defended twice but it
would have been better instead of he
should have left the bishop protecting
this pawn and what he should have done
was to bring this bishop back here to
trade this piece off completely even
game anyway Bishop to e6 it's not a real
bit it's just a minor minor move bad
move
so in chess notation that's a question
mark exclamation will move err it's not
he's not going to lose the game or
anything okay now white plays Queen to
Bishop two and the computer says the
game is still even we're almost done
black this knight here it can't go here
because the pawns protected they can't
go here it can't go here you can't go
here this is no longer good square for
the knight White has no threats against
the King side he doesn't need the knight
anymore on the Kings side he's going to
move the knight here and move it over
here where he has more squares so he
moves it back now black would like to
maybe move the bishop here and then move
the knight here white is going to move
the pawn here to block this pawn and
drive the bishop back he plays b4 bishop
retreats now black wants to trade that
bishop so black doesn't really mind
retreating white takes takes to the
bishop queen takes bishop and now white
plays Knight to e2
Knight to e2 is the wrong idea for white
notice the knight here is fairly well
placed it can go here and it protects
this pawn retreating here you don't want
to retreat in the we're in the middle
game now we're out of the opening you
don't want to retreat in this you after
so he voluntarily retreated and it's not
the best move well there's a better
retreat actually so retreating is okay
the computer says he should go here
as then he can come up to this square
and from here he can go up here so they
went to the wrong square anyway
black now opposes rooks the knight comes
over here and black moves here so black
defends this square with Bishop Knight
and rook and the knight can't go here
and the rook opposes this rook the Queen
and rook adequately protect this pawn
and white retreats this Knight and guess
what the grandmasters decided at move 32
what do you think they decided they
agreed to a draw
end of game they it's a the computer
says it's completely even it agrees with
them there's no point see how white has
maintained his four rows but he hasn't
penetrated black black has maintained
his four rows and kept white from going
up here where white could attack him
it's completely balanced even okay so
that's the that's our game is an example
of the chigorin defense it's still very
popular it's one of the most popular
defenses to the rear Lopes even today
and chigorin invented it around 1895
you
[Music]